[Musik]
deutschland an diesem sonntagabend ein
zweigeteiltes land zwischen corona frust
auf der einen seite und corona hoffnung
auf der anderen seite corona frust wut
am wochenende in kassel hat sie sich
entladen bei einer großdemonstration von
mehreren tausenden abermillionen sitzen
zuhause und warten verzweifelt auf einen
ausweg aus dem lot und dann stück davon
gab es eben am wochenende in rostock bei
diesem fußballspiel von hansa profi
fußball zumindest mal wieder vor 777
zuschauern ja und inmitten diesem kampf
zwischen hoffnung und frust kommt nun
dieses papier hier rein der
beschlussentwurf für den morgigen corona
gipfel und der verheißt nichts allzu
gutes nämlich eine verlängerung des
logins bis tief in den april hinein und
möglicherweise wieder härtere maßnahmen
geht es denn wirklich nicht anders das
diskutieren wir jetzt hier bild die
richtigen fragen live der zoff um einen
wieder noch härteren lockdown hier live
bei bild die frage ob diese woche noch
mehr dicht gemacht wird die diskutieren
wer hier mit dem heimlichen
gesundheitsminister spd
gesundheitsexperte karl lauterbach mit
fdp chef christian lindner mit der
tübinger pandemie beauftragten lisa
federle und dem cdu generalsekretär in
sachsen anhalts sven schultze ihnen
allen einen schönen guten abend ich habe
gerade schon gesagt wir erleben gerade
ein land zwischen hoffnung auf der einen
seite und frust auf der andern
deutschland zwischen hoffnung und frust
wir können heute von hoffnung und dem
übergang übergang in eine neue phase
sprechen weil wir ja alle in den letzten
monaten in unserem land sehr viel
erreicht haben man kann es drehen und
wenden wie man will wir müssen zurück in
den job deutschland zwischen erste
lockerungen und der angst vom nächsten
haben
daun die wut auf der straße am
wochenende in kassel die so lange
aufgestaute lust auf urlaub in plötzlich
hunderte new yorker fliegern mit
tausenden deutschen urlaubern wieder
geschlossene einkaufsstraßen in hamburg
in tübingen ganz anders hier geht
shoppen mit negativen test auch die
berliner philharmonie mit einem ersten
konzert vor etwas publikum und
profifußball in rostock mit knapp 1000
zuschauern und gleichzeitig dass das
nächste frost papier der bundesregierung
die vorlage für den morgigen corona
gipfel ein lockdown über ostern hinweg
ja herr lauterbach das ist das papier
das morgen beraten und dann etwas anders
auch beschlossen wird wie können sie ja
lauterbach guten gewissens dafür werben
oder dafür eintreten dass die maßnahmen
jetzt noch einmal verschärft werden
müssen es sogar ausgangs beschränkungen
über nacht geben soll
na ja das ist ja nur eine überlegung
dieser ausgangs stecken vielleicht lässt
sich das abwenden
aber wir sind mitten in der dritten
welle der pandemie und wir haben eine
neue mutation wenn diese mutation nicht
gekommen wäre hätten sie jetzt das
gröbste hinter uns und wir tatsächlich
jetzt bestehende locker und erfolgreich
genug gewesen um das ganze so
einzuschränken dass wir es bis zur
impfung durchschlagen hätten
jetzt haben wir über diese gefährliche
mutation b17 und das ist tatsächlich
bisher keinem land gelungen in diese
also schnell viel schneller der akademie
mit dieser mutation in den griff zu
bekommen oder dass es ausgangs
beschenken in dem lokal geben etwas es
gibt keinen gegen beispiellos gelungen
wäre ohne das ist deutlich an stärke und
dann kannst du ungefähr zusammenfassen
über einen monat betrachtet würden sich
irgendwo zwischen vier- bis achtmal so
viele menschen anstecken und dann wartet
das problem ist also die krankheit
verläuft noch schwerer und sie verläuft
somit oft bei 70 jährigen so schwer wie
früher die alte mutationen die auch
gefährlich war über 80
also würden sie also würden sie aktuell
herr lauterbach morgen wenn sie mit am
tisch saßen
auch für solche ausgangs beschränkungen
antreten dann will ich nicht also
ausgangs beschränkungen sind die ultima
ratio man muss versuchen das zu
verhindern und die einzige möglichkeit
das zu verhindern wäre das tatsächlich
das test konzept steht das also zwei mal
in der woche in den schulen getestet
werden kann und in den betrieben an dass
ich das verhindern
aber diese test kapazität wird er
derzeit fieberhaft aufgebaut und
ansonsten muss man tatsächlich sagen ist
also hier in japan sehr harter lockdown
notwendig gelockt und den wir haben und
das liegt nicht an dass alternativen
gäbe sondern also diese mutation ist so
ansteckend dass zum beispiel wenn ein
familienmitglied infizierte sich in der
regel alle anderen also infizieren
das war bei der alten variante nicht
wenn zum beispiel ein kind infiziert war
dann sind auch die eltern danach nicht
infiziert worden oder umgekehrt und das
gibt es ja nicht immer alle und wir
diese schweren verläufe zu verhindern
muss man entweder mit seiner locker und
plus ausgangs beschränkungen arbeiten
oder aber mit einem sehr strengen test
konzert was also voraussetzung hat das
zwar in der woche in den betrieben und
in den schulen getestet was man ja
vielerorts bisher eben oder in den
meisten orten und städten nicht
hinbekommt herr lindner
bisher zumindest wie könnten sie die
verantwortung übernehmen im moment den
deutschen zu sagen dass es das nicht
braucht das es ausgangs beschränkungen
so wie sie hier in diesem papier stehen
im moment nicht braucht das ist auch
eine verlängerung bis zum 18
das lockt bei uns möglicherweise nicht
braucht hallo ich bin zunächst mal der
auffassung dass ausgangs beschränkungen
immer unverhältnismäßig sind also wenn
sich angehörige eines haushaltes draußen
an der frischen luft bewegen sehe ich
keinen grund ihnen das zu untersagen da
könnte man kontakt beschränkungen
nachdenken die ausgangssperre
als ich immer für unverhältnismäßig eine
zu scharfe freiheitseinschränkung und
wenn es nach der fdp gegangen wäre dann
wäre diese
maßnahme dieses instrument überhaupt gar
nicht ins infektionsschutzgesetz
geschrieben worden
zum zweiten müssen wir noch die lage
betrachten ja corona ist gefährlich und
die aktuelle mutation verändert die lage
noch einmal höchste aufmerksamkeit
höchste sensibilität ist erforderlich
niemand darf die aktuelle gefahr
relativieren
auf der anderen seite müssen wir aber
auf der basis von konkret sichtbaren
fakten über grundrechts einschränkungen
sprechen
die gegenwärtige situation in den
krankenhäusern ist noch nicht bedrohlich
wir haben dort aber sehr offen doch wir
haben gottlob sinkende sterbezahlen
gottlob hat sich dort die situation
verändert wir haben einen zu langsam
aber immerhin einen fortschritt und
deshalb mein dritter gedanke herr weise
sollten wir jetzt andere maßnahmen
vorziehen stadt den lock down zu
verlängern oder zu verschärfen das
bedeutet das statt notbremse im turbo
das heißt schneller vor impfen
gegebenenfalls zwischen erst und
zweitens den zeitraum strecken damit
mehr menschen an impfschutz erhalten
flächendeckend in die test konzepte
hineingehen auch dort mehr tempo hygiene
konzepte im alltag und mehr vertrauen
dass die bürgerinnen und bürger sich
verantwortungsvoll angesichts dieser
gefahr verhalten denn herr lauterbach
sieht mit sicherheit zu recht
gesundheitlichen risiken und hat dort
große expertise
ich sehe aber auch die sozialen
gesellschaftlichen und wirtschaftlichen
risiken und auch die dürfen nicht gering
geschätzt werden lassen sie uns gleich
vertiefen noch mal herr lauterbach weil
sie auch karten einsteigen wollten über
die lage der krankenhäuser das ist
hochinteressant das möchte ich gleich
nochmal vertiefen möchte aber ganz kurz
noch mal bei diesem papier bleiben dass
dort morgen beraten und beschlossen wird
herr lauterbach noch mal ganz kurz und
knackig verlängerung des lok downs bis
zum 18 april bis über ostern hinaus
unter den jetzigen voraussetzungen wo
wir wissen wie langsam wie impfen und
das ist mit dem testen nicht so klappt
wie gewünscht
halten sie das für notwendig ja oder
nein
soja oder wenn und aber wenn wir es
nicht tun dann haben wir in der zweiten
april hälfte haben wir dann an die
inzidenz und 200 und das würde dazu
führen dass wir also in fünf wochen
später sieht wurde stelle sieht man über
fünf wochen später nach der infektion
die deutlich an den deutlichen als drei
wochen nach der infektion sind
intensivstationen voll und fünf wochen
später sterben die leute daher also muss
man immer nach vorne rechnen was man dir
sein infektion etwas das in fünf wochen
bedeutet man kann nicht abwarten bis es
soweit ist und wenn wir an die inzidenz
in der zweiten aprilhälfte von 200 das
bedeuten dass die sterbezahlen deutlich
ansteigen würden sich möglicherweise
mindestens verdoppeln würde
das betrifft auch sehr viele menschen in
der mittleren lebensphase die also eine
sehr lange lebenszeit verlieren würden
und die die es nicht so wichtig nicht
staaten haben oft ladengeschäften das
heisst also jetzt abzuwarten bis der
intensivstation in drei wochen voll sind
die entwickeln die infiziert und
verläuft das sind intensivpatienten von
drei wochen fangen jetzt und die toten
in fünf wochen von jetzt so lange dort
wenig warten weil er ist das ohne wenn
und aber richtig man darf also bis april
wir müssen diese schwere phase zu
überbrücken und jetzt die nerven zu
verlieren und dann noch einmal 10.000
nutzer zu gefahr zu gefährden 10.000
tote unnötiger war es in kauf zu nehmen
was steht in keinem verhältnis
frau dr federle sie sind notärztin den
tübingen und nicht nur sozusagen das
sondern sie sind pandemie beauftragte
dort vom oberbürgermeister boris palmer
frau federle
sie haben ganz viel hoffnung gemacht in
den letzten wochen und monaten und die
hoffnung bestand auch darin dass man nie
aus berlin da drauf gucken konnte auf
tübingen und hoffen konnten
vielleicht ist bald ganz deutschland
tübingen im moment sieht es aber eher so
aus dass
ist bei ihnen auch in tübingen bald
wieder so aussieht wie in hamburg wo am
freitag sofort er sagt wieder abgedreht
wurde und gesagt worden er jetzt immer
über 100 einkaufsstraßen wieder dicht
nix mit termin shopping zum beispiel
also sieht's in tübingen bald wieder so
aus wie hier auf diesen bildern aus
hamburg also ich hoffe nicht aber eins
muss ich ganz kurz sagen weil sie das
falsch gesagt habe ich bin nicht
pandemie beauftragte vom
oberbürgermeister palmer sondern von der
kv kassenärztliche vereinigung und da
gibt es in jeder stadt ein in baden
württemberg aber ich hoffe dass wir mit
unserem pilotprojekt dass wir sehr
konsequent durchführen wir testen ja
seit november letzten jahres regelmäßig
ganz konsequent bieten tests an
und jetzt haben wir wirklich test statt
somit pflicht tests die leute dürfen
sonst gar nicht in die geschäfte rein
und wir hoffen einfach oder auf uns dass
wir dadurch die infektionsrisiken wieder
minimieren können bisher war es auf
jeden fall so dass auch wenn überall im
land die zahlen gestiegen sind wir sehr
viel getestet haben und trotzdem der
erste kreis in baden württemberg waren
der unter 50 war weil wir eben die
vielen getesteten darunter die positiven
heraus gezogen aktuell haben sie
irgendetwas bei 60 inzidenz wäre es
glaube ich nicht wo sind sie 860
ungefähr glaube ich heute 8 68 7 und
landes bei 103,1 erscheint obwohl wir ja
schon seit zwei wochen geöffnet haben
und erst seit letzter woche pflicht
tests in der form durchführen sind wir
deutlich noch unterm landesschnitt
das heißt die rechte damit selbst wenn
und es wenn der wilden kerzen wenn jetzt
eine rolle rückwärts
für weite teile des bundes kommen morgen
für weite teile deutschlands dann
erhalten sie natürlich an ihrem weg fest
und glauben dass sie trotzdem das
richtige beispiel der erfolgreiche weg
sind das gegenbeispiel sind ich ich kann
das natürlich so auch nicht sagen aber
ich glaube wir sind den menschen langsam
blick auch in eine alternative zumindest
mal auszuprobieren ohne dass wir jetzt
menschen leben riskieren das ist für
mich gar keine frage ich bin ärztin das
steht für mich an höchster stelle
aber wie herr lindner vor hinaus schon
gesagt hat wir haben wahnsinnig viel
kollateralschäden auch und ich kriege
zunehmend menschen die depressiv sind
mit alte menschen die mir sagen wann bin
ich überhaupt noch auf der welt ist ja
meinen enkel seit einem jahr nicht mehr
und so weiter also war heute aktuell und
zb ja oder menschen die mich anrufen
weil sie ihre existenz verlieren und
weil die kinder kaputt gehen seelisch
kaputt wir haben hier eine kinder- und
jugendpsychiatrie die so voll wie nie
zuvor und es sind schäden die sind auch
angst zu nehmen vor allen dingen werden
die immer mehr auf uns zukommen die
sehen wir jetzt noch gar nicht so und
deshalb glaube ich ist es einfach ganz
wichtig auch noch eine andere
möglichkeit auszuprobieren
ich bin aber die erste die diesen
versuch abbrechen wird wenn ich das
gefühl habe das funktioniert nicht so
lange die aber im landesschnitt gleich
also weiter unten vom landesschnitt sind
und im verhältnis nicht mehr ansteigen
obwohl wir geöffnet haben heißt es ja
dass wir zumindest ein korrektes
schutzkonzept haben und wie gesagt wird
testen testen testen in ganz thüringen
also mit einem solchen schutzkonzept
halten sie ausgangs beschränkungen vdr
federle für nicht notwendig aktuell nach
ihren erfahrungen
also ich glaube im moment ist es ich
glaube im moment ist es bei uns in
thüringen nicht notwendig und ich würde
es gerne noch probieren wie es
funktioniert ob wir das hinkriegen ich
meine wie gesagt eigentlich müssten wir
bei dem vielen testen was wir tun
deutlich über dem landesschnitt liegen
weil es heißt ja immer testen testen
testen und es dann steigen die inzidenz
das tun wir aber nicht wir liegen
deutlich unter dem landesschnitt
das heißt wir fischen die positiven raus
sie kommen sofort in quarantäne und die
können definitiv niemanden mehr
anstecken und wenn sie mal beobachten
was den letzten wochen passiert ist das
heißt die menschen halten sich immer
weniger an die regeln
die kommen gar nicht mehr damit zurecht
das interessiert hier auch gar nicht
also das heißt wenn ich die menschen
nicht mitnehmen dann kann ich das virus
auch gar nicht bekämpfen weil wir
nämlich der wird von dem virus sind das
ist eine interessante atomkonferenz
richtig gegend sie sagen was bringt uns
ein lockdown wenn die alle nicht mehr
mitmachen herr schulze sie sind
generalsekretär der cdu in
sachsen-anhalt was würden die menschen
morgen sagen denn am ende dieser sitzung
dieser videokonferenz- dieses corona
gipfels morgen tatsächlich ausgangs
beschränkungen stehen wie werden sie das
erklären dass das ihre kanzlerin
beschlossen hat dann ja guten abend aus
magdeburg ich glaube die menschen würden
es in keinster weise verstehen ich kenne
das thema ausgangs beschränkung von
meinem arbeitsort in brüssel binger
abgeordneter im europäischen parlament
auch da gibt es die ausgangs
beschränkung ich glaube nicht dass das
was hilft weil es würde ja bedeuten
irgendwann von 0 uhr bis 5 uhr früh
beispielsweise und da tummeln sich die
menschen in der jetzigen zeit nicht auf
der straße und das hilft uns glaube ich
auch nicht und wir sollten nicht noch
mehr angst oder beschränkungen in die
bevölkerung bringen sondern wir sollten
über perspektiven reden und nicht sehe
das ganz genauso wie meine vorredner
auch wir müssen den menschen auch ein
stückweit licht am ende des tunnels
zeigen dazu gehört für mich
beispielsweise dass wir nicht mehr nur
über inzidenz reden sondern vielleicht
auch über neuen kroner indikator in dem
beispielsweise auch darüber gesprochen
wird wie hoch ist denn die impfquote wie
hoch ist die anzahl der neuinfektionen
wie hoch ist beispielsweise auch die
auslastung regional vor ort der
krankenhäuser dass das auch alles mit
reinspielt wir brauchen regional
unterschiedliche lösungen sicherlich
gibt es kreise landkreise die extrem
hart betroffen sind dann müssen die
lösungen aber andere sein als in
landkreisen die ich hier auch in
sachsen-anhalt habe wo die wert im
moment unter 30 liegen
lassen sie uns die menschen dort nicht
erklären dass sie genauso behandelt
werden wie anderen er schulze lassen uns
bei dem punkt krankenhäuser gerade
bleiben den weg schon mal an getippt
haben herr lauterbach
das ist ja ganz wichtig eine
bestandsaufnahme zu machen aktuell dann
das ist ja die hauptbegründung für alle
locker uns gewesen ihn zu verhindern
dass die krankenhäuser die
intensivstationen überlastet sind wie
voll sind aktuell die intensivstationen
und herr schulz hat angedeutet
man muss nicht mehr so streng auf den
incidents wert gucken nicht mehr drauf
gucken wie viele sich anstecken sondern
vielleicht
wer steckt sich da an nämlich junge
leute die möglicherweise eben nicht mehr
auf die intensivstation kommen ist das
die hoffnung ist es so
nein da nicht auch so herr karagiannis
von der also die vereinigung der
intensivmediziner der die ausschreibung
macht und mit dem ich in engem kontakt
steht das ja noch mal da hatte auf den
punkt gebracht wir haben jetzt also am
beginn der dritten welle haben wir auf
den intensivstationen mehr patienten
bereits mit die bahn hat werden nur noch
beatmet werden als am ende der ersten
länder das heißt wir sind schon mehr
oder weniger voll bevor es überhaupt
losgeht
es gibt aber noch drei zusätzliche
probleme das erste problem ist die leute
die jetzt auf der intensivstation lägen
sind dort im durchschnitt 60 jahre alt
viele zwischenfälle zwischen 40 und 80
und die legen sehr viel länger weil eben
tatsächlich die frage ob jemand lebt
oder ich steh auf die entscheidet sich
nicht wie bei 85 jährigen in der ersten
woche der beatmung sondern diese
menschen werden in der regel viel länger
beatmet auf fünf oder sechs wochen
datums sind keine seltenheit
das heißt ich habe dann viel mehr leute
auf der intensivstation die länger
beatmet werden müssen und es kommen
immer wieder neue hinzu das heißt wenn
jedes beispielsweise doppelt so lange
warten
durchschnitt dann müsste ich doppelt so
viele betten haben und die gleichen
patienten aufzunehmen
wir bekommen aber mehr patienten
erinnerte sich selber den einsatz
ja also wir wissen jetzt wenn ich damit
rechnen dass wir also eine überlastung
nicht nur der intensivstation stationen
bekommen sondern dass wir auch sollen
folgende situation bekommen
wir haben eine situation der wende
tatsächlich das auslassen so werden wir
die intensivstation voll haben und
lassen die intensivstation mit co sieht
aus wie das können
das ist auch keine verheißung und es
wird ja übersetzt bedeuten uns sterben
pro tag ungefähr 1000 menschen
was bedeutet das und wer will das
riskieren wenn wir das zulassen also
wenn ich wirkend sage wir haben noch auf
der intensivstation
ich lasse zu viele reihen wie den tanz
in den tessin versorgen kann jeder
zweite stirbt erwartet werden muss auch
bei diesen jungen fans anzieht und
verläuft ja schwer beschädigter die
lunge sehr viel schwerer und daher wenig
dass 1000 todesfälle gauchos seiner
ersten 1000 durch säle aber die in der
syker passiert wie etwa kapazität waren
überlastet
ich darf es gar nicht so weit kommen
lassen er linda das ist jetzt für den
laien der sitz davor der zuschauer der
schaut sich das heute an und sagt na gut
wenn das halt die wahl ist dann können
wir nicht anders ist das so er lindner
ist das so dass wir wieder so viel angst
haben müssen ihren erfahrungen ihren
daten nach dass es eben gar kein ausweg
im moment geht um volle krankenhäuser
volle intensivstation zu verhindern
dass der eine überlastung des
gesundheitssystems verhindern wollen
dass der sterbefälle verhindern wollen
dass der schwere krankheitsverläufe dass
wir überhaupt neue infektionen
verhindern wollen ich glaube in diesem
punkt stimmen wir alle überein
das kann ja überhaupt gar nicht die
frage sein und dass wir möglichst
intelligente aber eben schutzkonzepte
benötigen die die pandemie bekämpfen das
müsste unter allen vernünftigen
verantwortungsvollen erwachsenen
menschen auch einvernehmlich sein
jetzt werden wir miteinander diskutieren
können was sind wirklich wirksame
schutzkonzepte ich meldete zweifel an
dass das schutzkonzept lockdown
inklusive am ende sogar der ultima ratio
der ausgangssperre
dass das wirklich wirksam und
verhältnismäßig ist man kann ja aus der
vergangenheit sehen wo haben haben die
infektion stattgefunden dass wir auf der
private bereich das war nicht der handel
das war nicht die gastronomie das war
nicht die kultur als war der private
bereich und da helfen jetzt die
allgemeinen lockdown maßnahmen nicht und
speziell bezogen auf die situation im
gesundheitswesen kein zweifel
wir wollen keine überlastung und jede
hospitalisierung jede
intensivmedizinische betreuung die wir
vermeiden können er ist ein gewinn an
sich war wir auch die langfristigen
schädigungen durch die erkrankung sehen
müssen
stand heute ist die situation aber weit
entfernt von überlastung der
intensivmedizin welche die aktuelle zahl
richtig vor augen habe dann haben wir
1600 patienten die beatmet werden
bei insgesamt 37.000 krankenhausbetten
in der intensivmedizin wiederholt das
nochmal 37.000 betten 1600 beatmete
cobit stimmen die zahlen nur ganz kurz
stimmen die zahlen ihrer auffassung nach
auch herr lauterbach haben sie dieselben
zahlen ungefähr die gleichen zahlen
ich darf ich ansatz dazu sagen ein
einziger cupid patient der beatmet
werden muss findet typischerweise
zwischen fünf und zehn personen
das heißt es geht hier nicht um die zahl
der betten soll es jeder einfach
schlicht um die sache lautet ich habe
ich muss tatsächlich das ist also der
aufwand ist gigantisch also die die 60
die jetzt auf jeder der dort das
bestätigen wollen also die gesellschaft
für intensivmedizin ich stimmt ja dem
was ich hier sage blick nutzer hilft ein
blick ins netz internet in die
verlautbaren von der pfeife oder
karagiannis von gestern die stimme mir
dazu die sagen einfach nicht begreifen
dass die lage ist dramatisch wenn wir
jetzt also mit fast 2000 kurvig
patienten in die dritte welle strafen
hat mir das nicht lange weil das
personal will sagen sie ja lauter da
jetzt sind wir jetzt 30.000 zusätzliche
werden wird es keinen unterschied mache
nicht was diese spezielle partner
sondern jetzt sind wir uns ja einig das
war ja auch hier punkt herr lauterbach
das schutzkonzepte das verhindern
könnten dass test konzepte das
verhindern können dass wir noch härtere
maßnahmen jetzt ergreifen müssen
frau federle das beispiel in tübingen
direkt vor der nase und lebt das aber es
gibt auch in anderen orten in ganz
kleinen ganz ähnliche beispiele wie
jetzt zum beispiel in augustusburg in
sachsen
die kleine stadt augustusburg in sachsen
im erzgebirge ganz in der nähe von
chemnitz nicht einmal 5000 einwohner
wohnen hier und doch auf augustusburg
könnte schon in wenigen tagen ganz
deutschland schauen denn die stadt will
auf machen
trotz steigender corona zahlen
bürgermeister dirk neubauer weil es
wichtig ist weil wir davon ausgehen
können möglicherweise wiederholt sich im
herbst 21 20 und wir müssen gerüstet
sein einfach für kündigt immer das
gesamte leben immer wieder runter fahren
das ist ökonomisch nicht sinnvoll und
das macht auch gesellschaftspolitisch
langsam ein problem ist neubauer etwa
leichter nicht nein er hat ein ganz
klares konzept vor allem mit diesem
schnelltests zentrum
hier kann sich jeder bewohner der stadt
kostenlos testen lassen
ist der test negativ gibt es einen 3
tagespass für alle restaurants leben
dienstleistungen freiheit von corona
maßnahmen die digitale eintrittskarte
ins normale leben auf der website der
stadt übersichtlich erklärt
so gibt es einen knopf da können sich
registrieren kriegen einen per e mail
ein qr-code geschickt dann kann man hier
beim telefon in die wolle packen so wie
ich das jetzt hier gemacht habe und dann
ist ja quasi ein elektronisches ticket
und damit gehe ich jetzt hier ins
testzentrum halte das vor wird
eingescannt dann haben die meine daten
das wird per scan verheiratet mit einem
test mit dem test gehe ich zum abspricht
und verlasse ich ganz schnell dass hier
wieder
wir wollen ja hier auch keine
infektionsketten bilden und kriegt dann
das ergebnis per e mail
und wenn es ein negatives ergebnis wird
automatischen system dieser code
freigeschaltet
statt mit weitsicht so nennt sich
augustusburg selbstbewusst die kleine
stadt im erzgebirge
ein beispiel für ganz deutschland
und hier ist auch uns zusätzlich
zugeschaltet neubauer bürgermeister von
augustusburg wir hören die warnungen
hier in der runde auch vor allem von
ihrem parteikollegen karl lauterbach
machen die ihnen angst angesichts
steigender zahlen gerade in sachsen
wir sind ja nicht leichtfertig
ich denke nur dass wir einen
gesellschaftlichen schutz
gesundheitsschutz natürlich auch
aufpassen müssen dass wir den menschen
perspektiven zeigen und ich beobachte
mit sorge gerade im ländlichen raum was
das mit gesellschaft macht und wir
werden an diesen folgenden jahre zu
tragen haben und ich bin überzeugt davon
und das ist ein bisschen der
schwierigkeit in deutschland wir sind in
sachen digitalisierung jetzt nicht so
weit vorn
das sehen wir in allen bereichen und da
gibt es auch eine gewisse skepsis
aber wir haben ganz einfache tools sie
ganz einfach ermitteln wenn wir die
konsequent anwenden dann kann man das
auch sicher gestalten und können sie ihr
projekt jetzt vergessen weil jetzt
aktuell diese woche die rolle rückwärts
kommt oder am sie behörden mäßig alles
in der tüte sozusagen dass sie
unabhängig von den zahlen die bei ihnen
auch rund um 200 liegen ihr konzept
durchziehen können ab ende nächster
woche
dazu setzt das mal auf die instanzen
kommen also diese orts instanzen die
sind natürlich in größeren städten in
wirklicher anhaltspunkt bei 4512
einwohnern sind 19 infektionsfälle eine
inzidenz von irgendwas um 400 das ist
für uns kein realistischer wert also
hier muss man tatsächlich auch mal
gucken ob man das sicher anders
übersetzt das zum ersten zum zweiten
habe ich dem papier aus dem kanzleramt
gesehen dass ausnahmefälle in regionen
tim modellcharakter immer noch
genehmigungsfähig sind
es müssen die länder erklären und wir
sind mit dem freistaat im gespräch das
ist ein bisschen hin und her das ist
nicht ganz einfach aber wir bleiben dran
wir sind wissenschaftlich begleitet wir
haben ganz viel zuspruch aus ganz
deutschland bekommen seitdem das konzept
bekannt ist der viele wissenschaftler
die mit uns zusammenarbeiten wollen die
daten wollen die sehen wollen was das
tatsächlich macht und ich bin eigentlich
ganz guter dinge dass wir da noch ein
grünes nicht kriegen herr lauterbach
selbe partei anderes konzept oder ist
das genau das was sie wollen oder finden
sie das leichtsinnig was da im moment in
der kleine einheit in augustusburg
passiert in sachsen
also es ist konzertteil eine gewisse
ähnlichkeit aber so wie es hier
umgesetzt ist glaube ich so riskant weil
der antigen tester hier eingesetzt wird
wer gibt eine einigermaßen brauchbar
sicherheit dass man nicht ansteckend ist
für sechs bis acht stunden aber nicht
bereit tage und man muss übrigens also
beachten so test gemacht hat bei
asymptomatischen dass man menschen die
keine symptome
symptomatisch wird man ja sowieso offen
dass die gar nicht erst los gehen
sondern zu hause mache ich einen test
bei sektoren los und ich bin erkannt ich
bin haben nach bin angestellt wird aber
noch keine symptome
dann ist der test in sechs von zehn
fällen positiv gezeigt dass dann aber
vier von zehn fällen über sieht also
erneuten krieg nur kurz den einfach
sagen kann somit kann man glück haben
dass man es für 6 bis 8 und zwar
angesteckt ist aber nicht ansteckend da
kann man glück haben
aber spätestens also am späten abend es
morgens mache bin ich abends schon
vollkommen sozusagen ungetestet und dann
200 dritten tag bin ich ohne jede
testung unterwegs ist schaffen dass wir
gefährlich zu sein also herr neubauer
herr lauterbach sagt hochriskanter
lauterbach hat den kleinen vorteil muss
es den bürgern gegenüber in augustusburg
nicht verantworten ist das der punkt
naja ich noch einmal zurückspulen also
diese drei tage sind ein politischer
wert ich habe auch gesagt wir sind ja
nicht leichtsinnig mit steigenden
tendenzen kann man das anpassen also wir
können das noch zum tagespass machen das
ist im system ein klick dann habe ich es
umgestellt darum geht's in dem fall gar
nicht ich möchte aber auch etwas anderes
hinweisen wenn wir sagen testen testen
testen dann muss ich als vertreter der
kommunalen ebene jetzt mal die frage
stellen warum wir dann nicht testzentren
bundesweit aus dem boden stampfen dass
wir einfachen hat nur damit zu tun dass
wir gesagt haben wir machen jetzt eins
das macht die kommune selber das
finanzieren wir selber da hilft uns
niemand kein freistaat kein sonst so
gewährt wir gehen da ins finanzielle
risiko weil wir glauben dass es wichtig
ist das ist eine super frage eher
neubauer das eine super frage ich glaube
das wird im moment jeder der uns folgt
genau denken warum herr lindner können
sie erklären warum es nicht überall
tübingen warum ist nicht überall in
deutschland augustusburg kann ich
versuchen wir haben in deutschland eine
politik die alles zentral
planwirtschaftlich aus dem ministerium
mit bürokratischen verwaltungsverfahren
regeln will
wie gut das klappt haben wir jetzt über
zwölf monate erlebt wir müssen das
öffnen
wir müssen die kreativität von
bürgermeistern wir müssen die
kreativität auch von betrieben und das
verantwortungsbewusstsein der menschen
nutzen
im grunde müssen wir die rechtlichen und
technischen voraussetzungen dafür
schaffen dass in jedem drogeriemarkt in
jeder apotheke in jeder arztpraxis ein
testzentrum entstehen kann
da müssen gar nicht die kommunen 1 auf
mannes muss bereits flächendeckend
massenhaft getestet werden wenn die
marktwirtschaft 1 kann dann ist es doch
schnell produktion umstellen mit
knappheiten umgehen dafür zu sorgen dass
ressourcen an der richtigen stelle
eingesetzt werden das testen wäre unsere
chance und gestalten sie erweisen
zweiten gedanken ich finde dass nämlich
ausgezeichnet was in neubauer macht so
muss man das tun er sagt ja selber wir
passen gegebenenfalls an wenn sich die
zahlen verändern
und niemand spricht auch davon dass man
einen test macht und danach ist clubbing
angesagt und die leute lassen jede
vorsicht fallen sondern das ist doch ein
aspekt daneben wird doch vermutlich auch
bei ihnen weiter ft2 maske getragen
man hält den abstand so weiter wir haben
heute in nordrhein westfalen ein
landesparteitag der fdp in präsenz
gemacht mit einer enormen logistik und
schnelltest wir hatten auch diesen
elektronischen test aus meistern
trotzdem abstand und maske eben weil uns
ja bewusst war
der test ist nicht der freifahrschein
alle vorsicht fahren zu lassen aber ist
ein baustein das brauchen wir und da
will ich nochmal sagen respekt vor den
abwägungen von mehreren kollegen
lauterbach aber die bundesregierung und
die berater der bundesregierung
unterschätzen die sozialen und
wirtschaftlichen folgen ihrer politik
und die sprechen über gesundheit
abermillionen menschen nehmen schaden an
der seele durch die pandemie bekämpfung
und das hat langfristige enorme
gesundheitliche auswirkungen und deshalb
kann das nicht so fortgesetzt werden wie
bisher
es geht nicht um leichtfertigkeit aber
es gibt eben auch verantwortbare risiken
die man eingehen muss um schlimmeres
abzuwenden
herr schulze wenn man sieht wie schnell
das er schulze wir schnell dass in
augustusburg ging mit dem aufbau dieses
testzentrums wie einfach man dass da
gelöst hat mit der app und dem qr-code
wie das eben auch in tübingen relativ
schnell umgesetzt wurde daher seit
wochen mittlerweile so läuft heißt das
weniger merkel weniger bundesregierung
weniger darauf warten dass das zentral
regiert gesteuert veranlasst wird mit
all den bürokratischen hürden und
einfach los machen in der gemeinde in
der stadt
nein ganz so ist es nicht es ist sowohl
als auch es muss natürlich irgendwo
koordiniert werden aber wenn man über
die tests spricht dann wird mir
sicherlich auch keiner widersprechen
dass man wenn man die bürger zur test
auffordert als man den bürgern auch
einen anreiz geben muss also ich lasse
mich ja nicht testen und habe davon am
ende des tages
nichts also jetzt auf der einen seite
sagen wir machen alles wieder
verschärfen wieder alles wollen aber
auch dass viel mehr tests gemacht werden
wird so einfach nicht funktionieren
zweiter punkt ist diese regionalen
lösungen diesen absolut sinnvoll glaube
ich auch wir haben aber auch lösungen
für ganz deutschland wenn ich über die
doka abspreche oder andere dinge das
sind dinge die jetzt eingesetzt werden
müssen wir müssen am ende des tunnels
ein licht sehen und das kann alles dazu
beitragen deswegen sage ich auch testen
testen testen und auch auf solche
regionalen lösungen wie jetzt hier von
dem bürgermeister vorgetragen ist
vertrauen diesen lösungen auch vertrauen
schenken
wenn es so ist wie er laute was sagt was
ich ja nicht bestreitet da muss man halt
auch dafür sorgen dass dieser test nur
für wenige stunden gilt bis man zum
nächsten test kommt aber eher schulze
ehrlich gesagt guck ich neidisch nach
augustusburg und auch nach tübingen frau
federle würde das was sie in tübingen
machen nur in tübingen in einer stadt
ihrer größe funktionieren oder geht das
ganz genauso in köln hamburg münchen
berlin
das ist alles eine frage der
organisation unterfinanzierung das ist
der einzige punkt also ich kann sowieso
nicht nachvollziehen seit oktober
fordere ich schnelltests erst in den
altersheimen
daneben haben wir diese habe ich dieses
spendenprojekt auf die beine gestelltes
haben die tübinger gespendet die
schnelltest und wir wir testen zeit 26
november bis ende februar täglich
getestet und die leute konnten kostenlos
kommen zum testen und wir hatten die
ganze zeit super zahlen und dann bin ich
zu palma gegangen und habe gesagt so
jetzt gibt es die neuen tests wir müssen
die schulen testen ja wir müssen den
lehrern das know-how zeigen
ich glaube gerade ganzen zum in tübingen
ein damit die sie selber testen können
weil das ist auch irrsinnig teuer wenn
man da die apotheken und die ärzte
überall hinschickt und sie sollen dann
die firmen testen überlegen sich mal es
ist eine firma mit 1000 leuten wird
zweimal die woche getestet und es kostet
jedes jahr 15 euro nein wir lernen die
ganzen zum ein ich mache das schon die
ganze zeit und auch fahrschulen und so
weiter und dann können die das selber
durchführen mit den neuen test sei es
nur das vier-augen-prinzip und es
funktion
auch und des nächstes wir testen in
tübingen eine testpflicht täglich also
wenn ihr mann einkaufen gehen will dann
muss ich dann braucht da ein tagesticket
und ich dir ja nicht jeden tag einkaufen
nicht jeder muss sich jeden tag testen
lassen
also natürlich weiß jeder dass dieses
testergebnis nur kurzfristig hält und
auch keine hundertprozentige sicherheit
gibt aber es ist eine möglichkeit und
ich bin mir sicher ich verstehe es nicht
warum das nicht wie früher schon gemacht
hat als ich verstehe es nicht sein auf
rädern herr lauterbach stehst einfach
nicht und der bürgermeister von
augustusburg sagt dass auch mensch dass
das künste können sie überall in
deutschland machen warum nicht warum
nicht ich erkläre ich glaub ich glaube
ich kann das erklären und zwar ist es so
der vorschlag aus sodass wir
flächendeckend es auch von mir auch
gemacht worden
allerdings ist es so dass sie so ist das
ja auch für diese tests monoklonale
antikörper notwendig sind mit denen man
sieht es herstellt der eigentliche also
der test kits das ist ja nicht das
problem sondern die dafür notwendigen
monoklonalen antikörper müssen
produziert werden und die weltweite
kapazität also insbesondere in china
aber auch in südkorea in den vereinigten
staaten diese kapazität im wesentlichen
also her kommt die wahrheit begrenzt und
wir hatten auch so zum beispiel im
januar nur an gesamt so eine
gesamtkapazität in deutschland vor den
großen herstellern siemens und bosch und
ungefähr 45 millionen technik pro monat
für deutschland zu bekommen moment darf
ich das da die das stimmt nicht
stimmt nicht sagt frau federweißen ich
habe entschuldigung dass sie dazwischen
gehen aber das kind nicht ich kann
allein von apple beweisen dass ich eine
mail ab mit einem angebot was ich meiner
landesregierung im anfang ende januar
geschickt habe mit 20 millionen tests
innerhalb von vier wochen nur für baden
württemberg das entspricht offen gesagt
nicht dem was wir in berlin von den
selben firmen für gas deutschland
aufgetragen bekommen haben ich kann sich
es ist ganz schwer zu erklären weil man
kriegt das ja herr lauterbach federle
auch auf der kleinen ebene mit hier im
kommunalen an den schulen überall da wo
leute sich kümmern gibt es die tests
auch an den schulen
man kriegt die tests bei aldi gekauft
und was wir jetzt ist die kapazität ja
in eine andere sprache
profile hatte ja vorgetragen was dies
schon lange im oktober genau die völlig
klar im oktober genau und ich will nur
auf den punkt hinweisen über oft in
orchestern kosten hingewiesen hat dass
aus so die tester
die qualitativ hochwertigen test in dem
umfang nicht verfügbar waren
die also qualität der test ist im
zweifel besser geworden die sind dann
auch geprüft worden in regen versuchen
kalkar testen markt bringen die nicht
wirklich zu aber lassen sie uns
entschuldigen wenn ich sicher zu
unterbrechen lauterbach lassen sie uns
einmal bei den punkt heute bleiben also
in die vergangenheit gewendet sagt frau
federle klar es hätte schon viel früher
hätten diese test kapazitäten aufgebaut
werden können aber lassen sie uns ein
punkt heute bleibt morgen werden in
brandenburg kurzfristig habe gerade die
briefe gesehen schulen wieder dicht
gemacht die eigentlich geöffnet werden
sollten morgen weil man jetzt fest
stellt man hat die tests nicht und
schulleiter die aber einkaufen waren bei
aldi die können ihre schulen morgen
öffnen das heißt die sind nach wie vor
nicht in der lage flächendeckend in
brandenburg in berlin in vielen anderen
bundesländern die schulen zu öffnen test
kapazitäten bereitzustellen die dafür
notwendig sind nur da wo sich leute
gekümmert haben da gibt es dass herr
lindner
es gibt sehr viele schulen
es gibt viele schulen und auch für viele
betriebe selbst in der jetzigen
situation wo das angebot deutlich
gestiegen ist deutlich richtigen so
sieht es auch eine bessere qualität
nicht normal aber selbst jetzt gibt es
im internationalen nach für deutschland
nicht ausreichend ist um all diese
wünsche zu
das ist einfach nur eine ganz kurze
anekdote wie das hier läuft weil alles
planwirtschaftlich bürokratisch
organisiert ist mir erzählt jemand
und das geht mich gern der
bild-redaktion die kann dann
nachrecherchieren an der grundschule
wird ein testzentrum eingerichtet die
tests sind da vom senat in berlin wird
eine person abgestellt die testen soll
aber sie hat keine schutzkleidung die
schutzkleidung wurde nicht mitgeliefert
die schutzkleidung könnte man für 10
euro um die ecke kaufen macht keiner
also finden keine tests statt das ist
die realität eines landes das komplett
in die kroatische selbstfesselung
geführt worden ist wo es leider an
vielen stellen keine bereitschaft gibt
pragmatisch zur hand kann ihnen sagen
herr lindner der an stelle die menschen
völlig überfordert sind und weit mehr
tun müssen als ihre pflicht wäre zb im
gesundheitsbereich und herr lauterbach
das ist eine verantwortung von
regierungen die ihre partei mit trägt er
schuld wie sie sind darf jahre frage ist
ja ganz kurz das wusste frage bringt
ganz ehrliche und offene frage bringt
uns das jetzt warte dass wir politik
machen
ich habe ausdrücklich nicht doch lassen
nämlich den einsatz sein
ich habe zum beispiel in ihr in
nordrhein westfalen gibt es wird nicht
angeboten in den schulen wäre kann es
gemacht hier könnte es anfangen und
sagen in köln funktioniert gar nichts
die landesregierung fdp geführt die
schulen können nicht betrieben werden in
meinem wahlkreis die eltern kommen die
kinder sind auch die psychosoziale
folgen wo ist der fdp landesregierung
diese aber da stimmen wir sofort über
ein herr lindner lauterbach das ist aber
auch nicht der punkt wir werden müssen
nicht benennen welche partei ist gerade
nicht hinbekommt aber wir müssen ganz
klar sagen wo es funktioniert und wo es
nicht funktioniert und wenn schulen
morgen die eigentlich öffnen sollten in
brandenburg in berlin nicht öffnen
können weil die test nicht da sind aber
her
neubauer in augustusburg kriegt das hin
frau federl in tübingen kriegt das hin
dann müssen wir hier diejenigen benennen
dies nicht hinbekommen herr neubauer
moment jetzt heller dauert ganz ganz
kurz
ganz kurz das was jetzt sichtbar wird
ist ein grundsätzliches problem in
diesem land wir arbeiten in der politik
inzwischen komplett an der kommunalen
ebene vorbei und das was bei uns alles
organisierbar werden wir sind bei
digitalisierung schule dass wir weniger
impfen wir reden
stück für stück alles dinge die wir der
kommune tun könnten
wenn man mit uns zusammenarbeiten würde
aber nein über jahre und jahrzehnte sind
immer mehr entscheidungskompetenzen
weggeworfen wird von der kuh bude
es wird es sind immer weniger
finanzielle mittel da es ist nur
harakiri es ist wirklich auch nur noch
mängelverwaltung die wir haben damit
stirbt demokratie menschen in meiner
stadt wissen nicht mehr warum sie sich
noch einmischen sollen weil es
eigentlich gar nichts mehr zu bestimmen
gibt das ist die realität die pandemie
macht das nur sichtbar und die politik
hat sonst das glück dieser politik als
sonst ausdrücken ist faire entscheidung
meistens aus jahre sichtbar werden im
pandemischen fall ist es in echtzeit und
deshalb fällt es uns genau da würde ich
gern das feld pragmatismus und
verantwortung zu übernehmen das fehlt
und ja es gibt ja zwei dinge zum einen
wollte ich kurz ein lauterbach sagen
doch doch ich glaube man muss das schon
jetzt auch in der verantwortung
parteipolitisch zu ordnen herr kollege
lauterbach weil die gesamtstaatliche
krisenstrategie wird vom unionsgeführten
kanzleramt mit assistenz der spd
organisiert da haben die länder wir gar
nichts zu sagen muss klar sagen wir sind
sogar machtlos ist nicht immer ein
erinnern
das mache ich jetzt zu ende den punkt
nur dadurch dass die menschen die
möglichkeit haben in wahlen und umfragen
zu votieren ist eine möglichkeit gegeben
die krisenstrategie zu korrigieren und
jetzt zur neubauer er hat vollkommen
recht
hören wir doch mal zu was die kommunale
ebene sagt landkreis
es ist ja kein unverantwortlicher mann
der herr landsberg lauterbach das werden
sie den ja wohl nicht vorwerfen
und dass der ja die pflegesätze genau
neustart in der pandemie politik städte
und gemeindebund da sind auch
spd-bürgermeister dabei die haben ein
misstrauensvotum gegen ihre pandemie
politik vorgelegt wie wollen den instanz
wert von 50 auch nicht mehr akzeptieren
oder von 100 sondern wir wollen eine
andere grundlage herr schulz hat ja eben
eine ähnliche bemerkung in diese
richtung gemacht deshalb nehmen sie das
doch bitte war das ist doch inzwischen
ruppelt sie das sogar in ihren eigenen
parteien ist weil wir neubauer zurecht
sagt die kommunale ebene
die pragmatisch handelt die
verantwortung übernimmt die mit den
bürgerinnen und bürgern in kontakt ist
die vor ort sieht was schulschließung
für eine bedeutung hat was das mit den
familien und den kindern und
jugendlichen macht das müssen sie doch
bitte zur kenntnis nehmen schuld sei ein
neustart in der handelspolitik sie sind
der einzige hier in der runde oder der
nächste der in der runde wahlen hat in
sachsen anhalt für sie muss das ja
schrecklich klingen wenn ein neustart
von einem neustart die rede ist das
bedeutet nämlich dass sie brutal
abgestraft werden in der cdu für das was
sie im letzten jahr in sachen pandemie
politik gemacht haben sind sie auch für
einen solchen neustart für mich klingt
das erst mal schrecklich wenn ich jetzt
schon wieder mit kriege dass sich die
beiden vertreter hier aus berlin wieder
parteipolitisch gegenseitig angehen das
hilft uns doch jetzt überhaupt nichts
und ich kann ihnen sagen wir haben in
sachsen anhalt jetzt gerade den
landkreis der bei uns am härtesten
betroffen ist
da haben wir in den schulen alle lehrer
durchgeimpft 90 prozent der lehrer sind
jetzt geimpft wurden in diesem landkreis
wir werden dort wenn die schüler morgen
zur schule gehen test entsprechend auch
zur verfügung stellen und werden die
schulen offen lassen obwohl der
entsprechende indexwert über 100 liegt
das heißt es gibt schon möglichkeiten
nieder zu machen und für uns als cdu in
sachsen anhalt gilt jetzt hier einst wir
wollen vernünftige politik auch machen
und keine parteipolitik und schon gar
nicht mit corona versuchen in
irgendeiner form den wahlen zu gewinnen
weil das wollen die leute nicht höher
leute wollen sehen wie lösen wir die
probleme die wir jetzt haben und nicht
das werfen wir uns gegenseitig ja das
stimmt das stimmt aber trotzdem wird
natürlich die nächste wahl ist totaler
abrechnung über die korona politik das
ist ja klar das ist das thema das die
menschen beschäftigt dass deren alltag
im moment am allermeisten berührt
deswegen ist es ja ganz klar dass
erstklässler ist wegen heftiger politik
machen
frau frau feder und deswegen müssen wir
doch vernünftige politik machen und
aufhören uns doch teil politik
vorzuwerfen was da ein hätte besser
machen können das gilt für die spd das
gilt für die cdu das gilt für fdp als
opposition genau so lasst uns vernünftig
politik machen für die bürger und lasst
uns nicht vorwerfen wenn er was der eine
woanders falsch gemacht hat dass jemand
nicht in der lage war schutzanzug zu
kaufen das hat nicht ersparen und nicht
frau merkel zu wahren konnten sondern
das müssen die dann vor ort lösen so
keine arbeit an euch kaufen aber
entschuldigen ich finde wir sind schon
in einer demokratie und hier gibt's
schon politische verantwortung die
zugeordnet werden muss bei allem
verständnis für den wahlkämpfer schulze
der sagt ja wir sind alle in einem boot
und wir haben eine staatliche
verantwortungsgemeinschaft und im grunde
ist niemand genau partei würden sie sich
zuzuordnen
das überzeugt mich nicht wofür haben wir
wahlen das nämlich menschen politische
verantwortung zu ordnen
unterschätzte sie müssen sich dann schon
fragen lassen wenn sie das so mit dem
hohelied der überparteilichkeit jetzt
machen sie haben eben in ihrem ersten
statement davon gesprochen dass sie den
incidents wert von 50 und 100 alleine
nicht mehr akzeptieren wollen ganz
wichtiger punkt zurecht und völlig zu
recht vorschläge gemacht und an dem
punkt möchte ich nochmal bleiben weil es
hier um die sache die talente nach
da ist uns die frage an sie gestellt war
das jetzt ihre privatmeinung die cdu
sachsen anhalt die landesregierung von
sachsen-anhalt wenn sie eine solche ja
übrigens sehr richtige meinung vertreten
was folgt daraus konkret für die bürger
für die politik exakt ganz konkrete
frage sachsen-anhalt lösen sie sich von
dem starren schauen auf den incidents
wert also lassen sie schulen auch
geöffnet geschäfte termin shopping zu
wenn der wert über 100 beziehungsweise
200 steigt die wir haben in sachsen
anhalt in der vergangenheit auch unseren
weg wir sind unseren weg gegangen im
rahmen dessen was möglich vor wir werden
komplett überall abweichen aber genau
das was ich vorhin sagte ist auch ein
stück weit ein ding was aus
sachsen-anhalt heraus diskutiert wird
wir werden auch beim thema urlaub zu
ostern da haben wir vorgeschlagen unsere
ministerpräsidenten das thema
kontaktloser urlaub das heißt dass die
menschen innerhalb eines bundesland auch
zu ostern meinetwegen von magdeburg in
den harz fahren können ohne dass sie
dann andere menschen treffen auch im
harz wandern zu gehen sollte dann schon
möglich sein das sind dinge die auch von
uns vorgeschlagen hält das ist ein punkt
der in sachsen-anhalt diskutiert wird
ganz wichtig dass das ein punkt der
wahrscheinlich ja auch in dem papier
morgen landen wird auch aus sachsen
anhalt unter anderem da gibt es aber
unterstützend wirken der gründe ist uns
dies aber sie und konkret von uns okay
kleiner punkt für sie aber jetzt geht es
um die großen punkt incidents werte da
könnte ihr herr haseloff
ministerpräsident aus sachsen-anhalt
morgen in der schalter sitzen und sagen
das mache ich nicht mehr mit diese
starren ich möchte ein neustart in der
pandemie politik ich möchte dass wir uns
lösen von diesem starren incidents wert
mit sicherheit wird er das auch machen
er macht hat es in der vergangenheit
auch schon gemacht und er wird mit
sicherheit auch möglichkeiten mit den
anderen ministerpräsidenten diskutieren
da sind ja auch alle für offen über
verschiedene dinge zu diskutieren und
dafür sind sie auch morgen da deswegen
sage ich ja die sitzung morgen wird eine
der wichtigsten sitzungen seien die die
kanzlerin mit dem mindestens
ministerpräsidenten in den vergangenen
monaten gemacht hat definitiv aber
federle noch einmal um sie in die runde
zurück unbedingt frau federle ich würde
gerne vor allen dingen auch von ihnen
wissen wie sie in tübingen das
eigentlich machen wenn jetzt der wert
dann doch steigen sollte über die
hunderte oder möglicherweise sogar über
die 200 würden sie dann an ihrem konzept
erst mal weiter festhalten würden
schulen dann zum beispiel offen bleiben
bei ihnen also das ist schwierig zu
sagen weil wie gesagt das hängt von der
intensivstation ab das hängt davon ab
wie wir die kontakt nachverfolgung
durchführen können das hängt davon ab
wie viele menschen geimpft sind vor
allen dingen aus diesen schwierigen
wollen gruppen auch und es hängt auch
davon ab ob vielleicht doch irgendwann
auch ein medikament zur therapie dar ein
mehr investiert wird aber was wir jetzt
an der runde wieder aufgefallen
es wird ständig diskutiert und
entschieden dass dem anderen das zu und
keiner guckt wirklich richtig an also
ich will jetzt nicht alle unter einen
kamm scheren aber das habe ich seit
monaten mit der landesregierung also mit
der mit dem sozialministerium
baden-württemberg erlebt ich kämpfe seit
monaten damit und habe dort immer wieder
angefragt und es ist irgendwie in der
politik wirklich schade dass niemand
einfach mal zupackt und sagt so und ich
mache jetzt einfach ich übernehme ich
arbeite pragmatisch und übernimmt
verantwortung und irgendwie ist es trat
auch wieder so das ist mir immer alles
theoretisch so bleibt hat denn die
praxis und das was wir wirklich tun
müssen was wollen die bürger denn die
wollen nicht mehr von uns irgendwas
hören dass wir noch reden und uns
überlegen und uns gegenseitig die schuld
zu
das kriegen sie ja lauter warum nicht
wenn mit dem mit dem was sie sagen heute
abend das argument geht irgendwie nicht
weg sie erklär uns aber gleichzeitig
sitzen da die pragmatiker und die
praktiker mit neubauer mit frau federle
dies halt machen und da funktioniert
warum nicht im großen raum ruf nicht
jeder in tübingen und in augustusburg
sagt wie macht ihr es okay ab morgen
machen wir es auch so wir haben doch ein
konzert ist doch ein praktisch das paar
tische konzert ist doch frau getragen
das praktische konzept ist wir testen
zweimal in der woche die schüler und
zwei mal in der woche in den betrieben
wenn man das macht uns stärker an dem
tag an der test bescheinigung aus so
dass an dem tag auch eingekauft werden
kann und dann werden die lockerungen
genossen an dem tag wo der test gilt
nicht für drei tage sondern den dem tag
plan funktioniert das und dass er
wissenschaftlich gesichert ist ganz
etwas anderes am dritten beschlossen
und das werden wir morgen noch
anschließen und ich will noch mal
daraufhin lassen es ist das beste rezept
das ist einfach wissenschaftlich
gesichert das senkt den er wird unter
die grenze die wir benötigen
und ich finde das auch vollkommen unter
komplexen hier immer vom starren blick
auf den incidents welt gesprochen
das ist doch das gab das stimmt doch gar
nicht wir blicken auf den rwe auf die
entwicklung des instruments wert auf die
altersverteilung
sie zierten saade intensivpatienten die
jetzt schon intensiv vorgestellt
diese konnten diese konzepte die jetzt
war vorbereitet werden die sind doch
alle das lest doch das mit hinein und
nochmals zu ihnen der linse natürlich
ist parteipolitik im wahlkampf wichtig
ohne wenn und aber
aber wir sind noch nicht im band im
wahlkampf an wir brauchen jetzt die
richtigen konzepte
ich hatte abstand davon genommen für die
beschaffung der testung der test für die
schule sind die länder zuständig und die
kommunen die länder aber in erster linie
und das ist in nordrhein westfalen gar
nicht gelungen
ich habe das aber nicht gesagt weil ich
einfach keine partei jetzt haben sie
jetzt haben sie es ja gerade gesagt der
lauterbach jetzt haben sie es ja gerade
laut und deutlich gesagt ganz konzern
noch ja ja machen sie alles richtig aber
machen sie es ja gerade doch her eher
lauter war dann genau bringt und sie
weiter top stories nicht ins theater war
dort bringt uns nicht weiter sie haben
es alles untergebrachter lauterbach in
dem sie gesagt haben was sie alles nicht
sagen wollen herr neubauer schüttelt die
ganze zeit den kopf herr lauterbach lobt
die konzepte die alle steht er sagt das
haben wir beschlossen und das werden wir
das war ein super satz das werden wir
morgen nochmal beschließen aber halt
nicht umsetzen das ist doch das problem
die tests sind sich da wirklich war das
also das was sagen
neubauer einmal einmal herr neubauer da
es ist wirklich schön hier das zu sehen
weil das sehe ich ja auch sonst im
fernsehen jeden tag
ich will ein beispiel sagen warum das
nicht funktionieren kann
in edeka markt in unserer nachbarstadt
hat 140 mitarbeiter mit kundenkontakt
diese 140 mitarbeiter sollte er jetzt
auf eigene kosten zweimal die woche
testen haben sie das mal hochgerechnet
ja und dann dann höre ich hier die
kommunen soll sind verantwortlich die
die tests zu organisieren ich als
kommune kann das mit meinem häuser
überhaupt nich ständen noch zumal ich
dieses testzentrum bei der kv diesmal
abrechnen darf manchmal denke ich
manchmal tatsächlich wirklich ist vier
geräten über sachen und die kommen dann
bei uns an und ich denke war okay
wer hat euch diesen plan gemacht nichts
gegen nicht wirklich ich lege großen
wert darauf auch hier mal zu sagen dass
sie
das ist hat laut prognosen die kann man
ja rückwärts nachverfolgen die stimme
alle dass es kaum ein problem das
problem ist dass wir aus diesen
erkenntnissen zu wenig machen dass wir
zwölf monate lang uns nichts anderes
einfällt und immer wieder abzuschließen
aufzumachen abzuschließen aufzumachen
und einen haufen geld zu mobilisieren
statt mal vorwärts zu denken ich lese in
der zeit wie das teil wahr macht und
schäme mich in grund und boden ist es
unfassbar federico federle sie wollen
sollte dazu sagen dass ich kann ich kann
das nur bestätigen
bei uns in tübingen ist es so dass die
firmen derzeit ihre tests bilder selber
bestellen und selber bezahlen und wir
lernen die ein damit die dies selber
durchführen können weil die finanzierung
einfach nach wie vor nicht geklärt ist
es weiß keiner werde es ihm zeigt außer
ich bestelle den apotheker und lasst den
apotheker zweimal die woche die ganze
firma durch abstreichen aber wer zahlt
denn auf dauer
überlegen sie sich mal was das kostet
und es kostet das schon fünf euro wenn
der apotheker aber 15 euro pro
abgestrichen mitarbeiter und ist eine
firma mit 1000 leuten ist und das
zweimal pro woche macht wer soll das
bezahlen
das ist alles nicht na ja doch gelehnt
deswegen sie haben sich noch gelesen vor
vier jahren das konzept doch gelesen was
wir am dritten beschlossen haben dass
wir morgen wie das wirkt aber nichts
wenn dies gar nicht umsetzbar ist sage
ich leute sagen das konnten sie haben
das konzept auch gelesen es geht nicht
um abstriche durch also an apotheken
sondern es sind selbst stellte unter
anderem gemacht werden die kosten
ungefähr 450 prozess weil ich das darf
aber wie kriegen wir schon derzeit nicht
bezahlt wo sollen sie den er kriegen die
gerade die helme auf eigene kosten
derzeit ja bardowick habt jetzt die
automobil die die fahrschullehrer die
haben jetzt an staatsministerium einen
antrag gestellt dass sie wenigstens die
tests bezahlt bekommen das dann ist das
einfach geredet tut mir leid ich kann
nur sagen diese an der basis ist und das
aber es lag mit selbstständig zu tun
das sonst nicht im laden das sind sie
kennen doch das konzept das konzept
sieht doch vor dass die
arbeitgeber die tests für ihre abnehmer
bezahlen und da finden die verhandlungen
derzeit starb die letzte sitzung waren
donnerstag unter leitung von
bundeskanzlerin merkel
dort wird eine lösung gesucht das die
arbeitgeber tatsächlich für ihre
beschäftigten
diese tests zweimal pro woche die selbst
bezahlen und für die länder kommt also
kommen länder und der bund auf und damit
ist das konzept zum einen beschrieben
selbst ist zwar mal die woche in
betrieben und den schulen so dass man
daran den tag lockerungen kann und es
geht für einen tag das auch
wissenschaftlich hat und die
finanzierung seien bisher reißt die
kommen auf aber das geld kommt von
jürgens derzeit also in ein dessen
kanzlerin hier bis jede woche ihr
einfach meisten sie aber war darf nicht
alles kaputt reden was stimmt ist es
hätte gar nichts kaputt wir machen es ja
ja was als entschuldigung klingt nicht
wirklich nichts kaputt im gegenteil ich
habe mir mal zu machen doch einfach wir
reden und hören wir können das ist
umsetzbar ich war es aber ich das nervt
ehrlich gesagt auch ein bisschen und ich
weiß dass in einer kleinstadt in
tübingen das gelungen ist durch
besonderes engagement das dort gibt es
zum teil zur verfügung stehen
ich weiß nur noch einmal darauf hin dass
man informationsstand der ist dass wir
dafür die test kapazität von gesicherten
wohl auch wissenschaftlich geprüften
test im januar und februar noch nicht
hatte noch mal ganz kurz verstanden herr
lauterbach wir verstehen auch er auch
ihre nöte wir verstehen sogar dass es in
der großen bundesrepublik vielleicht
manchmal etwas schwerfälliger ist so
klein ich verstehe aber nicht dass sie
jetzt sagen ich bin genervt davon dass
frau federle sagt bei uns läuft's gut
guck mal wie wir es machen kopiert das
doch bitte einfach sie sind genervt
man kann nicht einfach immer nur
kopieren
es müssen konzerte gesetzt werden also
wohl geprüft sind aber sie sind genervt
von der von der realität ist wovon sie
gelernt
er weiß ich jetzt versuchen sie mir ich
das wort im munde
ich frage sie sind ja ich will einfach
schlicht mehr kraft nicht dass der
eindruck der fehlhaltung dass das was in
tübingen gemacht und was ich oft genug
mit für fehlende maßnahmen vorgetragen
aber noch gelobt aber ich setze mich ja
auch für diese strategie sagt langer
zeit mit federlein ich will einfach
nicht dass der falsche eindruck im raum
stehen an dass dies in ganz deutschland
schon seit einem dreivierteljahr hätte
gemacht werden können ja jetzt will ich
einfach nicht lassen
aber jetzt
ich möchte einmal ganz kurz ihren in
strich ziehen kann dem brautpaar punkt
ich das kurz sagen darf ich glaube die
unglückliche formulierung von lauterbach
mit dem genervt die müssen wir jetzt
nicht weiter verfolgen er hat das ja
gerade eingeordnet was bekommt schnell
beine also ich habe jetzt verstanden wie
das gemeint hat und ich würde sagen das
können wir streichen aber ihre politik
punkt von ihnen nämlich schon aufgreifen
selbst wenn es im januar/februar nicht
flächendeckend aus roller gewesen wäre
ich spreche im konjunktiv dahinter
steckt ja nun auch wiederum eine
beschaffungs und planungs entscheidung
aus dem sommer weil wir haben im letzten
jahr immer schon nach südostasien
geschaut wie dort getestet getestet
getestet worden ist war meine erwartung
dass irgendwo höheren ortes in der
bundesregierung das alles für
deutschland vorbereitet wird selbst wer
das nicht erfolgt ist wir haben wir auch
februar waren wir noch nicht so weit wir
sind jetzt kurz vor ostern also jetzt
müsste es möglich sein
und ich mache einfach ein vorschlag ist
es wenn die regierung sich dazu nicht in
der lage sieht die bundesregierung dann
nehmen wir das zur kenntnis
aber wir lassen unser land davon nicht
weiter lahmlegen sondern wir geben uns
in die hände der praktiker vor ort in
die verantwortung der kommunen und
erlauben marktwirtschaftliche lösungen
dann werden nämlich betriebe anbieter
unternehmer kommunalpolitiker
medizinerinnen vor ort eine lösung dafür
finden der ich sage es nochmal das
vokabular dass ich jetzt wähle kommt aus
einem anderen bereich aber ich glaube es
ist trotzdem einschlägig der
planwirtschaftliche weg der pandemie
bekämpfung der wird dich weiter
erfolgreich sein können er war es auch
bislang nicht wir sollten einen anderen
weg erproben wir haben hier praktiker
sitzen geben bei denen mehr
verantwortung und vertrauen in
lauterbach herr neubauer sie sind direkt
angesprochen ich möchte noch einmal ganz
kurz am ende von ihnen hören wie weit
der weg dahin war bis sie dieses
testzentrum aufstellen konnten bisher
ein konzept stehen hatten wie viele
hürden sind ihnen da in den weg gelegt
worden wie viel anträge musste sie
stellen wie viel stunden mussten sie
kämpfen bei der landesregierung und das
zu bekommen was sie jetzt haben also das
was wir jetzt haben haben wir selbst
gemacht insofern habe ich dafür
eigentlich nicht eine minute ein gesetz
außer der organisation derselben gaben
tolle partner der adac hat uns der
abwehr gestellt
technisch ist unternehmen das die dass
das system entwickelt hat hat uns die
technik gestellt wir sind jetzt
irgendwas war keine ahnung 5000 euro die
wir erstmal selbst bewegt haben
selbst das zentrum wird jetzt von dem
privaten unternehmen betrieben das jetzt
mit der kvv anders abzurechnen mit der
landesregierung reden wir jetzt schon
seit wochen wir haben es ja auch
geschafft in der aktuellen
allgemeinverfügung freistaat sachsen die
möglichkeit für pilotprojekte zu haben
allerdings steht dort drin bis zu einer
instanz von 100 im landkreis und im ort
und das bin ich jetzt wieder beim einer
mini kommune diese 100 die kann ich will
ich packen und es macht auch aus meiner
sicht und auch aus wissenschaftlicher
sicht da wirklich nicht von mir sondern
von den vielen menschen die uns da
begleitet die sagen wenn wir etwas
probieren wollen dann brauchen wir die
pandemischen verhältnis und nachzuweisen
es geht und dass da rede ich nicht von
experiment und da werde ich nicht von
großem risiko ich habe vorhin schon
gesagt wir haben das auch gelernt diese
drei tage übrigen auf die wir kommen zu
planen abgeleitet von den wöchentlichen
tests in der bundesgesundheitsminister
jedem bürger zu stehen wollte sind aber
überhaupt sofort in der lage das auf dem
tagesticket runter zu brechen wir sind
ja nicht das ist eigentlich das thema
fakt aber ist bisher haben wir das alles
alleine gemacht und das was ich bekomme
vom freistaat jetzt erst wieder ist
wieder eine rolle rückwärts und wir
fangen wieder von an und so langsam
verliert da auch echt den glauben dass
wir noch in der lage sind in diesem land
wirklich mal kühlen kopfes loch schon zu
denken
das wünschen wir allen hier in der runde
ich dann gegen ganz herzlich fürs
mitmachen heute herr neubauer nach
augustusburg und glaube wir alle auch
wer lauter wacht er sagt das hält er im
moment für hochriskant rückt natürlich
die daumen dass das am ende funktioniert
und dass alle gesund bleiben
bei ihnen im ort eine schlussrunde würde
ich gern machen mit ihnen herr lindner
unter lauterbach vor allem ums thema
urlaub noch mal wir haben heute in der
bild am sonntag gesehen die schlagzeile
dort vom vizekanzler und
spitzenkandidaten der spd für die
bundestagswahl olaf scholz der sagt
derjenige der jetzt ostern verreist der
gefährdet unseren sommerurlaub das
ehrlich gesagt herr lauterbach hat mich
etwas genervt ich würde im moment auch
nicht nach mallorca reisen und doch muss
man doch ganz einfach sagen es ist halt
erlaubt sie haben es erlaubt das lka hat
mallorca von der liste der risikogebiete
genommen und jetzt wird ein schlechtes
gewissen gemacht und sogar gesagt wer
jetzt reist riskiert den urlaub für alle
im sommer na ja wir haben seit einer
woche jetzt die brasilianische mutation
auf mallorca das erinnert die situation
natürlich
und wenn dort leute hinreißen die sagen
immer die britische mutation hinbringen
also was sie aus deutschland anreisen
mit der gotischen mutation deutschland
ankommen und die brasilianische noch mit
zurückbringen dann haben wir natürlich
eine situation die nicht richtig ist und
ich möchte das einfach nicht mehr geht
es einfach da wir müssen die schulen
wieder öffnen können und wir können uns
keinen weitern incidents anstieg leisten
bei appelliere ich an jedem nicht zu
reißen und diejenigen die gras sind und
zu bekommen müssen getestet werden das
ist das mindeste was man verlangen kann
wenn man eine solche riskante reise ja
bisher sie sagen jetzt das mindeste was
man verlangen kann doch mal es war ja
ausdrücklich jetzt erlaubt in dem moment
in dem moment haben die leute gebucht in
dem moment ist das geschäft losgegangen
haben ganz viele fluggesellschaften
zusätzliche flieger gechartert die dann
auch zunehmend voll waren natürlich das
heißt es ist erlaubt worden und in dem
moment ist das angebot angenommen worden
jetzt wollen sie eine neuregelung wenn
ich es richtig verstanden habe wollen
sie es nicht mehr von risikogebiet nach
risikogebiet richten denn im moment ist
im ec dance wert nach mallorca kein
risikogebiet sondern sie wollen sagen
das ist ein mutations gebiet deswegen
von dieser neuen notation und deswegen
müssen alle reisenden sofort in
quarantäne wenn sie zurückkommen nach
dem test
wenn sie zurückkommen müssen sie
getestet werden das dann damit ihr
keiner sagen wir angst man darf dem
mechanischen fans machen keine
quarantäne
das ist wichtig diejenige der getestete
so negativ da muss aus meiner sicht in
quarantäne weil es noch kein
risikogebiet ist aber dass ein test weil
der rückkehr verpflichtet ist das halte
ich für die sprecherin epidemie logisch
das habe ich unbedingt notwendig war die
gefährlichste mutation die es überhaupt
gibt es die bisher also zumindest ist
die brasilianische ist ansteckend und
darüber hinaus wirken die impfungen
nicht komplett und diejenigen die schon
mal erkannt wagen können es auch
bekommen
das ist somit die gefährlichste variante
die wollen wir auf jeden fall ist jetzt
auf mallorca angekommen
daher müssen wir die leute die
zurückkommen müssen wir testen und das
ist aus meiner sicht verlangt herr
linder noch einmal abschließend zu dem
zitat des vize-kanzlers zurück also wie
gesagt erst hat man es erlaubt den
urlaub und dann macht man ein jahr mehr
als schlechtes gewissen in dem man sogar
sagt wenn ihr jetzt verreist da riskiert
hier für alle familien im sommer den
urlaub ist es fair test bei einreise
nach deutschland halte ich für ein
sinnvolles instrument und zwar nicht nur
nach der urlaubsreise auch nach der
geschäftsreise auch beim grenzübertritt
aus polen und tschechien
darüber kann man und muss man nachdenken
weil die einträge die wir von da gesehen
haben natürlich das infektionsgeschehen
in deutschland massiv beeinflussen und
ein test ist nun wirklich kein
unverhältnismäßiger freiheits eingriff
sondern eine investition in mehr
gesellschaftliches leben für uns alle
ansonsten sollte jeder genau prüfen
wohin er reisen will und muss selbst
wenn es erlaubt ist
ich persönlich würde raten dass wir ganz
tolle urlaubsdestinationen in
deutschland haben und ich würde mir sehr
wünschen dass mit schutzkonzepte die
regierungen in bund und ländern erlauben
dass wir von diesen urlaubsdestinationen
auch gebrauch machen können und ostern
herr schulze was sagen sie
die ihren bewohnern in sachsen anhalt
wie wird ostern verbracht wird das so
still wie weihnachten
nein glaube ich nicht und dem man schon
jetzt möchte ich erst mal sagen dass er
sich um seine aufgabe kümmern nämlich
dafür sorgen dass die menschen und die
unternehmen in deutschland ihr geld
kriegen was ihnen aus berlin zugesagt
wird erwarten die nämlich draußen ist
brauchen die auch und nicht um
irgendwelche sommerurlaub er sich
kümmern
fakt ist ich habe es ja vorhin gesagt
kontaktlose urlaub das ist auch unser
konzept das wir hier in sachsen anhalt
favorisieren aktuell und was zu mallorca
zu sagen das ist eine schizophrene
diskussion vom spanischen festland aus
madrid darf man im moment nicht nach
mallorca reisen aus großbritannien doch
mal zu ostern auch nicht nach mallorca
reisen und bei uns ist es jetzt erlaubt
ich bin genau da auch was ja lauter was
sagt das minimum ist dass man mit
sicherheit einen test machen muss aus
meiner sicht auch bevor man ins flugzeug
steigt negativen test vorweisen sollte
und natürlich auch wenn man zurückkommt
und dann ist das bei nicht
risikogebieten auch aus meiner sicht
zumindest ausreichend
ich danke ihnen für die diskussion wir
haben es jetzt kurz vor 23 uhr schon
danke fürs lange aushalten und lange
diskutieren das war lebendig wir schauen
alle ja gespannt auf den morgigen tag
was er bringen wird an weiteren
beschlüssen für unseren alltag möglichen
weiteren verschärfungen und eben darüber
haben wir eingangs in der sendung
diskutiert eine offenbar verlängerung
des logins bis tief in den april bis
weit über ostern hinaus danke ihnen frau
peterle ganz kurz wir haben heute gehört
erdbeben in tübingen
das hat mich kurz aufgeschreckt kurz vor
der sendung wie 18 uhr 30 oder so haben
sie davon was mitbekommen gab es das
wirklich ja es beim abendessen mit
meiner familie und hab gesagt ist es ein
abgeben das war das so kurz dass wir
eigentlich nicht gross beunruhigt war
okay das zumindest können wir friedlich
an diesem abend einen haken dran machen
dankeschön ihnen allen und gute nacht
sagen
ist kein politisches erdbeben ist es
nächste woche bis zum sonntag 21 50
möglich morgen dann die lange
sondersendung hierbei verlautbart hat
sich schon ausgeklinkt auch der muss
morgen früh raus morgen bei bild live
sondersendung zum corona gipfel hier
ganz genau aus diesem studio ab 11 uhr
danke ihnen
[Musik]